Tom Waits that song lied to me uh you
gotta lie to me baby I I you know
honesty is a funny thing but Tom Waits
also believes that God's away on
business so I think his words man and
who do we who are the ones that we left
in charge Killers thieves and lawyers
that's a Tom Waits quote well it must be
true then yeah
um I don't know how many I don't know
how many limbs I have but I will give
all of them to talk to Tom and he's a
very private person I feel like he's the
musical equivalent of Cormac McCarthy
yeah even if you get the interview
you're not I don't think gonna get in
there no I don't think you want like uh
honestly I don't think you want to I
think you've seen in his public
interviews over the years with Letterman
and
I think he just he is the Poetry I would
put Tom Waits
um Cormac McCarthy Maynard James Keenan
like these these are artists that like I
think they want the art to speak for
itself
they would like to be lessened they
don't want you to you know I remember
early early days of tool
that he like this he could not have been
less interested in the spotlight here to
the point where I think it was almost to
the detriment of the band early on
you know and that's there's no surprise
that those are three artists that I
think are unbelievable and in a category
of their own and that you hear their
performance like you can give me a page
of a Cormac McCarthy novel and I'll know
it's a Cormac McCarthy novel you can a
few notes of Maynard James Keenan or Tom
Waits voice you know that that's them
yes genius and genius highs from the
spotlight but you know doesn't stop me
from feeling sad about it but anyway
yeah that does I would like to hear that
she's the girl that got away yeah yeah
I'm just standing outside of that girl's
house
yeah just playing in your eyes with
Peter Gabriel yeah yeah